- Welcome, everybody.
Thank you for joining us
today for a hybrid seminar
sponsored by Program on
Refugees, Forced Displacement,
and Humanitarian Responses
at the MacMillan.
My name is Catherine Panter-Brick.
I am Professor of Anthropology,
Health and Global Affairs
at Yale, and today I have
the pleasure of introducing
and hosting our speaker.
Let me introduce you briefly
to professor Michael Pluess.
He is Professor in
Developmental Psychology
at Queen Mary University of London,
so obviously joins us here from the UK
for our hybrid seminar.
He came to the field of psychology
after training in chemistry, music,
and therefore has a very
interesting personal
and scientific background
to offer us today.
He's very well known
internationally for his work
on environmental sensitivity,
which anchors in science a notion
that some people are more effected
by the very same experience,
for example, stress
than others because they're more sensitive
to environmental conditions,
and that sensitivity shapes
our human development
over the life course,
as he shows in his work.
He's also known for work
on positive development and resilience,
evaluating interventions
aimed to promote well-being
in children and adults,
and he leads research
on mental health in humanitarian crisis,
which is where in the area
in which our work intersects
and how I came to know him
as a very generous,
highly productive scholar,
interested in interdisciplinary work
and transnational collaborations.
So it's really my pleasure to
introduce him to you today.
He'll talk about the
research that he has led
on mental health of
Syrian refugee children,
living in precarious
conditions in Lebanon,
and the work he has led on
phone-based psychological therapy
in Lebanon.
The title of this is, you know,
it's really a great
pleasure to welcome him.
The title of his talk today is
"Prevalence, Predictors and Treatment
"of Mental Health Problems
in Syrian Refugee Children."
Before we start, please know
that Dr. Pluess welcomes
questions, clarifications
or concerns during his presentation.
So if you have any, please
put that in the chat
or raise your hand, and
we'll be able to nudge him
to stop and respond to
you as he talks to us.
So welcome, Michael,
and it's a great pleasure
to hand off to you.
Thank you for joining us today.
- Well, thank you very much
for the kind introduction,
and it's really great to be here.
I've met Catherine quite a while ago
when I was at the very beginning
of developing this idea.
So it's fantastic to be able to be here
and to share where we've been,
and what we've managed to do
over the last few years.
So I wish I was there in person.
I was, in my music days
actually, I was at Yale once,
but, and I remember it was,
it's really a wonderful, beautiful place.
So let me start with giving an overview
for what I'd like to cover today.
So there's quite a few things.
I'd like to first give a
background, the Syrian context,
and then I'll introduce the BIOPATH study
and several findings.
So I will talk about the
prevalence and predictors
of mental health problems.
I will then talk about
risk and resilience factors
and the research we've done on that.
Then also talk about the
dynamic nature of resilience,
looking at the longitudinal analysis,
and then have some findings
on the biological embedding
of war exposure.
And then I'll talk about the t-CETA study.
This is about
the phone-delivered
psychological intervention.
I'll present some findings
on the efficacy of
phone-delivered treatment,
as well as the feasibility
and acceptability of
phone-delivered treatment.
And then I'll discuss those findings.
I will discuss them as
I present some of them,
but I'll be happy to be interrupted.
And then I'll try to
bring everything together
in the discussion and then have
some practical implications
at the very end.
I'd like to start, however,
with hearing from you.
And I have prepared some
questions on Mentimeter.
Obviously you're all experts,
but I'd like to know from you,
how many refugees do you
think that there are currently
across the world?
And so if you go on menti.com
and enter that code,
then you can enter your estimate
of what you think how many
refugee children we have today
across the world.
So that can just be a wild guess
to the best of your knowledge.
I'll have some more questions after that.
So it's worth logging in.
Okay, you can still enter that,
but I think most of the
answers are in the right area.
So the most recent data suggests
that there are about 85,000,
85 million refugees in the world,
half of which are children.
So it is between 40 and 45 million.
So you got that, right?
So that was an easy question.
The next question is a bit,
might be a bit more challenging
and because it's not, not
that obvious necessarily.
So out of these children,
how many do you think are suffering
from mental health problems?
In percentage.
What's your guess?
Well, we get a bit more of a range here,
but the majority suggests 50%.
That is,
I think the whole range
that we see represented here
is supported by the evidence.
And I'll talk a bit more about that,
and 50% is relatively high.
Okay, and then the last question
is the one regarding treatment.
How many of these children
that have problems
receive mental health treatment?
So how many of the refugee children
that actually have mental health problems
end up receiving mental health treatment?
What's your best guess?
Okay, so yes, that looks,
that looks about right.
We have quite a few refugee children
that have mental health problems,
and a very small number of
children actually receive help
that they need.
Great, so good responses,
and I will provide data on
all these questions today,
and yes, so you were quite
correct in that assessment.
Some background on the
Syrian refugee crisis.
So I'm not gonna go in great detail
because most of you will
be very familiar with this,
but this is a long, ongoing conflict.
So it's already 10 years
that this has been going on,
and it started with a conflict
between the Syrian government
and a few rebel groups,
and then turned into a
very, very complex proxy war
involving various parties
and has been in the news on
and off, not so much recently,
but the conflict is still ongoing,
although it's not the
same as it used to be.
The consequences are substantial.
So estimates talk about
half a million of deaths
and many refugees.
So there's 6.2 million Syrians
that are displaced within Syria.
Don't often hear about those.
We hear mostly about those
externally displaced,
which is about 5.6 million.
And when we look at those,
so the most recent numbers,
according to UNHCR,
which these are the registered refugees,
there are more refugees than
those that are registered,
but there are 5.6 million
persons of concern.
So these are registered with UNHCR,
and most of them are in Turkey
and then followed by
Lebanon, Jordan, Iraq, Egypt,
and as well as some in North Africa.
I think what's important to consider
is that most of the refugees
remain in the Middle East.
And that's obviously true
of most refugee settings
that refugees tends to, well, be displaced
within that country,
and then end up in neighboring countries,
although there's, in particular in Europe,
there has been a lot of
debates and a lot of,
at the moment, again,
with the situation in Belarus and Poland
with refugees coming over to Europe,
but actually most of them
are in the Middle East.
And it's only a small
proportion of the refugees
that have fled to Europe.
Importantly, for us, for my work,
is that 50% of the Syrian
refugees are children,
and they are significantly
affected by the crisis.
One important aspect is
that they are often not,
often don't have access to school,
and that's as well the
case with our sample.
So in our sample,
with families that have been
in Lebanon for several years,
about 40% of the children
have access to school.
And, the others not, even
though they are in a,
you know, in a relatively
stable refugee environment.
What do we know about the mental health
of Syrian refugee children?
Well, there are more
studies more recently,
and they actually suggest
that there's quite a range.
So when we look at PTSD,
the prevalence rates range
from 10% or 11% to 45.
Similarly for anxiety
between about 10% to 50%.
We see the same with
depression between 12 to 48%.
So this suggests that
there is wide variability
in those prevalence estimates.
So we need to do more to find out
what is actually the number
that we are looking at.
And there is likely a significant need
for mental health treatment
in Syrian refugee children.
And I'll report more on that later.
So it's obviously important to do research
in order to understand the
mental health problems,
as well as the needs of Syrian
refugee children, but also,
and that's what we try
to do is to identify
the specific factors and processes
that are involved in risk and
resilience of these children.
And that's important because
it would inform programs
as well as interventions.
And while we know quite a
bit about adverse events
and negative outcomes,
it's also important to
focus on protective factors
because it might be easier to,
or more feasible to
strengthen protective factors
than prevent adverse
situations from happening.
Because if there is a
conflict, it's ongoing,
we can't resolve the conflict,
but we can strengthen what,
you know, the protective factors
amongst those children and families.
And hopefully, you know, that
sort of research would help
to also allocate resources to
those intervention services
where they're most likely to
benefit the refugee children.
There are three specific
factors that are important,
that I think are important to consider
in that sort of research,
and the first one is developmental,
that development occurs in nested contexts
as proposed by Urie Bronfenbrenner
in his Ecological Systems Theory.
So when we look at an
individual developing,
we always need to consider
the developmental context
of that individual.
And Bronfenbrenner suggested
that an individual is nested
within a whole range of different systems.
So most importantly
would be the microsystem.
This is the immediate
context of the child,
so that would be the family,
peers, the school environment,
but these environments
are further influenced
by the availability of
services on the exosystem,
but also by cultural
facts in the macrosystem.
So if you want to
understand the development
of the individual,
we have to also consider
all these different systems
that represent the context
within which the child is developing.
But also the factors that then
have an impact on the context
within the child is developing.
So that's really important.
Another important consideration
is that we can look
at multiple levels of analysis.
So in psychology, which is my background,
we often look at the behavioral.
We ask people to complete questionnaires
or we interview them,
but in order to really
understand the pathways
across different levels of analysis,
we also need to look at
the neurological level,
at the biochemical level,
or at the molecular level
at the far end, extremes
at the genetic level.
And ideally we do all
of that to understand
how they all influence each other
and whether the behavioral
reflects what happens
on the biological level and so forth.
And the last point I already alluded to
is that it's important to not just look at
the absence of disease,
but also at the presence
of positive outcomes.
So there has been a lot of work
that would focus on the
negative effects of risk factors
and maladaptive outcomes.
And we need to do more work
to also look at protective factors
and the positive effects
on adaptive outcomes.
Obviously some work has been done on that,
but I think it's really
important to not just,
not forget that health is more
than just the absence of disease.
So we tried to do all of
that in the BIOPATH Study.
And the BIOPATH Study is a collaboration
between myself and colleagues
at Queen Mary University
of London and Elie Karam
and colleagues at IDRAAC
in Lebanon, and then our fieldwork
partner was Médecins du Monde,
and it was funded by NSCHE.
So the focus of the
study is really looking
at the individual differences
in response to war
and displacement.
We know that millions of children
are affected by war and displacement,
that many of them develop
psychological problems.
However, some do not develop
They seem to be resilient.
And this study is really
trying to understand
the biological underpinnings
of such individual differences
in response to war and displacement,
taking into account multiple
settings, as I mentioned,
with the biological systems theory,
looking at the family
environment, school environment,
the community, the neighborhoods,
availability of services,
but also looking across
multiple levels of analysis.
So looking at the
environmental factors, social,
but also psychological, neuroendocrine,
epigenetic and genetic factors.
And then we look at both
risk and protective factors,
both adaptive and maladaptive outcomes.
I will not present findings
about the adaptive outcomes today.
I'm not going to talk
about wellbeing outcomes.
Mostly we'll talk about
mental health outcomes,
but we will consider both
risk and protective factors.
And an important aspect of
this study is, you know,
longitudinal design.
It's very difficult to
do longitudinal research
in these settings,
or it's very challenging
to do any research
in these settings,
but longitudinal research
is particularly challenging.
And so that's why many of the
studies are cross-sectional.
And when I mentioned all these points,
Catherine obviously collected data
where she did all of those things as well
and is one of the few studies
that have achieved a longitudinal study,
looking at multiple levels
of analysis and settings.
The study design is that
basically we were interested in
war exposure and displacement
and how it has an impact on
both risk and resilience,
captured with psychological
and biological outcomes.
That's the main question.
Then you want to understand
how environmental risk
and protective factors
outside of war exposure and displacement,
as well as genetic factors
also have an impact
on these outcomes and how
they moderate the impact
that war exposure has on these outcomes.
And then an important aspect of the study
is to see whether the impact
of environmental risk factors,
war exposure and genes, are
mediated through DNA methylation
and impacted by genetic factors
and further elements of risk
factors on those outcomes.
So that's a baseline.
And then we look at
all those factors again
12 months later in the
followup assessment.
We did that with a sample
of close to 1,600 families.
So these are the children
plus their primary caregivers.
So the total sample is therefore about,
it's more than 3,000.
The age range that we aimed for
is between eight to 16 years.
And we collected that data
in end of 2017, early 2018.
And then a year later we
did a follow-up assessment,
and we were aiming for about
two thirds of the sample.
That's what we expected
we would be able to get,
so we didn't actually have the funding
to collect data from all.
We would have been able to
collect a bit more than this,
but there is about an
immobility of about two thirds.
So within a year, a third of
the refugees tend to move on.
A little bit about the
sample that we collected.
So an important point is
that our recruitment rate
was about 70%.
That means 70% of all the
families that we approached
for inclusion in the study said yes.
So that suggests that our
sample is sort of representative
of the refugee population
where we recruited from,
and I'll share a bit more
details about the location.
We ended up with a fairly
balanced gender split
between female and male children.
The age range ended up between
six to 19 years of age.
We aimed for a broad age range
because we wanted to look at
developmental questions as well.
We knew it would be very difficult
to have more than two
waves of data collection.
So we did sort of a compromise,
having a wide age range
and then collecting data
longitudinally once,
at two time points,
which allows us to look
at longitudinal questions
and taking the developmental
age of children
into account as well.
Most of them are Syrian, not surprisingly.
The caregiver was in
most cases the mother,
and in a small number fathers.
The measures, we collected
a lot of different measures,
so this is just a very simple summary.
So we basically collected
data on child and caregiver,
from child and caregiver.
We collected data on
their psychopathology,
on their wellbeing,
and then a wide range of
protective and risk factors
across the individual,
the social environment,
and the wider social environments.
And an important feature
is that we also collected
biological samples, so we
have saliva that we collected
for genetic analysis
and epigenetic analysis.
Both of these are genome-wide.
So we have genome-wide genetic data
and epigenome-wide epigenetic data.
So that's DNA methylation,
and we also collected hair samples
to look at three neuroendocrine variables.
So most importantly
cortisol. (cross talking)
- Michael, I have a couple
of clarification questions.
Hi, this is (audio blurs).
- Hello, good to see you.
- Nice to see you too.
The genetic data you
collected, only on the children
or also the parents?
- It's only the children.
So the biological data is
only from the children.
- And any reason why
you only did six to 19,
rather than younger children?
- The reason is that we
collected data from the children,
and they needed to be able to respond
basically to complete the data collection.
The data was not
collected in written form.
It was all in interview,
but the main reason is
that we wanted to ensure that
our measures would be suitable
for that age of children.
So if we wanted to collect
data from younger children,
we probably would have to use
different measures for them.
- [Participant] Yeah.
- So one of the challenges
is to find measures that work
for an age range between eight and 18.
- We could talk about it at
some point, but go ahead.
- Yeah, great.
Thank you.
Okay, the location,
you all probably know
where Lebanon is based.
The important thing is that Lebanon
is pretty much surrounded
by Syria, as you can see.
So that's one of the reasons
why many Syrian refugees
ended up in Lebanon.
Within Lebanon, we collected data,
which actually it's a
fairly small country.
We collected all of our data
in the West Bekaa valley.
So this is about an
hour, an hour and a half,
away from Beirut by car.
And some of the settlements
are fairly close to Syria,
so maybe just a 10 minute
drive from the Syrian border.
And we collected data
from about 80 different
refugee settlements.
And here is an example of one
of those refugee settlements.
These are all informal settlements
and relatively small settlements.
Here is a typical one.
You can see that they
have tented structures.
They have satellite dishes on them.
So they've been living there for,
some of them for several
years already, but it's still,
it's still a difficult life,
even though they have relatively
solid tented structures.
It does rain, and it
does snow in this region.
And it's quite difficult living there.
And here is the team that
collected data at wave one.
So we had 20 field workers,
two different teams that went
from settlement to settlement.
All the data was collected in interviews,
and we used tablets to do so.
So the interviewer was asking
all the questionnaire
questions directly to the child
in Arabic, and then was
recording that in the tablets.
Then we're uploading the data
the same day onto the service.
So we basically had real time data.
We always knew at the end of the day,
what data has been collected.
And then we're able to look at that data.
At the same time as the
child was interviewed,
another member of the team
was interviewing the caregiver
in a different section of the tent
or outside, which is the case here.
And I have a little video
that provides a bit more
of that context.
So let me share that.
So this, the sound is not
very loud, but it's in Arabic.
So I don't know how many
of you speak Arabic.
I don't.
So it's translated into English,
so you can read at the bottom
as the sound is not very loud,
but hopefully you'll get a bit
of the context of this study.
(speaking in Arabic)
- All right.
I hope you got a little bit of a flavor
of the data collection.
It was quite challenging
to get this study approved
by all the different ethics committees,
not so much in the UK, but in Lebanon.
So it took quite a while
to get this through,
and it was quite challenging
collecting the data,
but the team did an excellent job,
and we managed to collect,
I would say very high quality
data on a large sample.
So I will share some of these findings,
much of that is still in the progress.
So these are papers, none of
those papers are published yet,
but either submitted in,
on the review or they are
to be submitted very soon.
So these are still sort of
somewhat preliminary findings
in some cases.
The first findings I'm going to present
is about mental health
needs and treatment.
And the research question
that we want to address
with this analysis is the following:
We wanted to look at
what is the prevalence
of mental health problems
amongst our sample
of Syrian refugee children.
We wanted to look at what
are the main predictors
of those mental health problems.
We also wanted to look at
what is the perceived need
for treatment of Syrian refugee children.
And we asked the children
as well as the caregivers
whether they think their
child would need treatment
of mental health problems.
And the last question, we
then also wanted to look at,
what are common barriers
to available mental health services?
Asking the families whether
they are aware of any services
available to them and
whether they would use them.
And if not, why not?
This particular paper is
the work of my post-docs,
Fiona McEwen and Claudinei Biazoli.
So a little bit about the measures here.
So we used established self-report scales
to measure mental health.
So with depression, we used the CESD.
For anxiety, we used the SCARED.
Both of those were shortened
to reduce the burden of data collection.
They were reduced
based on very carefully
conducted pilot studies.
So we've basically collected
data on all of the items
and then run the factor
analysis and reduced them
to shorten them.
The PTSD scale was the full scale,
and externalizing problems
was the SDQ items,
but we added some additional
items that we created
based on DSM-5 for
conduct disorder and ODD.
And all those were based on child reported
except externalizing problems.
When we collected externalizing problems
based on child reports in pilot studies
that data was not very reliable.
So the other data seemed
to be more reliable
on child report, but
externalizing problems
was based on caregiver report.
In addition, we conducted
clinical interviews
in a sub sample with the many kids,
and that was a sub sample of 134 children
that were at different levels of risk
in order to create a representative sample
that represents the total sample.
So we conducted those interviews in Arabic
with the help of a local
clinical psychologist
and two trained counselors,
either in the clinic or in settlements.
And then all those cases were discussed
with the clinical supervisor
before agreeing on a diagnosis.
And here are the findings.
So we have basically data
from clinical assessments
in a sub sample of 134 children.
We then created cutoff
scores based on that sample
that we applied to the rest of the sample
based on child self-report
and caregiver reports.
But we also, as a third option,
we asked the caregivers
after asking them to
complete their self-report
about their own mental
health, we asked them,
do you think your child is suffering
from those problems as well?
So, and what we got, here
is the clinical example.
We got relatively high levels,
but within the margins
that all of you indicated
at the very beginning.
So post-traumatic stress
disorder was about 40%
based on clinical interviews,
externalizing problems around
27%, depression around 20%,
anxiety disorders was very
high with close to 50%.
And what is interesting is
that ADHD is not much higher
than we would expect
in non-refugee samples.
So it's particularly depression, PTSD,
and anxiety disorders
that and externalizing,
those that are particularly higher
than it would be in other child samples.
When we, based on those findings,
then created cutoff scores
for our other measures
and apply that to the whole sample.
We basically found the same thing,
which is not surprising
given that the cutoffs
are based on the clinical sample,
but that's basically replicated
across the whole sample.
Actually the anxiety disorder measure
was normally distributed,
and we were very cautious
using the anxiety measure here
because we don't think
it's a good measure.
It's not a good measure to use
to indicate mental health problems
in this particular sample.
The same measure that
we used with our cutoffs
has been used by our colleagues in Turkey
in a different, in a Syrian refugee sample
living in Istanbul,
and they found much
lower prevalence rates.
And I think that our sample
is of particular high vulnerability.
So the third finding is
that we ask caregivers
to report on what they think,
whether their child needs help.
And interestingly, we find
that it's fairly similar
to our cutoff scores
and clinical interviews.
So 35% of the caregivers thought
that their child needs help
for PTSD or has significant PTSD problems.
And with depression,
it was a little bit
higher than the others.
With anxiety disorder, it was a bit lower.
We only asked them in relation to PTSD,
depression, and anxiety.
I think the most important, yes.
- Sorry, if it's okay to jump in.
I just have a question on that.
So for the caregiver reports,
are these whether they think
that their child is experiencing this,
or whether they, I guess, both
think their child is experiencing this
and should receive professional care?
- Yes, I have to specify that.
With this particular question
was whether their child has,
is suffering from those problems.
Basically we've,
the caregivers completed
their own PTSD measure.
Once they completed
their own PTSD measure,
they were interviewed about that.
They were also asked,
is any other member in your family
suffering from those problems?
Is your child suffering
from problems like that?
And then in a consequent question,
we ask them about whether
the child needs help.
So that's why I confused
those things, but yeah,
so they were always asked,
the data that you see here
is when they were asked
whether the child is suffering
from similar problems
as the ones that the
caregiver just reported.
I think the main thing to
take away from this scale,
from this table here is that
when we look at any mental health problem,
we look at prevalence rates close to 60%.
So very high.
Initially we looked at
the self-report scales,
and we felt maybe that's
gonna be lower ones.
We look at the clinical interview data,
but even with clinical interviews,
there were individual interviews
conducted by mental health,
by trained people, we
get very similar scores.
So a very high prevalence
of mental health problems.
The next one is, finding
is looking at comorbidity.
And I don't wanna say too
much about that, but this is,
these are the comorbidity findings
in the clinical sample, right?
So we have the same as well
in with the self-report data,
and findings look very similar.
But the main message here
is as would be expected
comorbidity is the norm.
So in almost 90% of the
cases, we have comorbidity,
usually involving PTSD and something else.
- Sorry, do you mind if I just ask quickly
what the rates in the
previous table were in Turkey
and whether you think this?
- Oh, in Turkey.
- Yeah, and also whether you think
that the discrepancies
indicate differences
in prior experiences before
arriving to the country
or because of environmental factors
or just like the income of that family?
- Yeah, so I don't, I don't
remember the exact numbers,
but where we found about 50% of children
are above the cutoff scores for anxiety.
In the Turkish sample it was
I think between five and 10%,
so significantly lower.
And we think, so we,
this is still something
that we have to look at,
but we think that our
sample probably, you know,
are living in very much
more difficult context
and may have more of higher war exposure,
but we haven't compared that.
So I can't say whether that's the case,
but what seems to be the
case is that the context
that they're living in right now
might be much more challenging
in Lebanon than in Turkey.
And that might explain some of that.
- Yeah, that's certainly
been my understanding
as someone that has done work in Turkey
and seen the statistics in Lebanon.
It's the conditions are way
worse, but then of course, I,
you know, you're always curious about,
you understand that a lot of that
is from the current
environmental circumstances,
but then you also wonder how
much of this also relates
to the prior circumstances.
Thank you.
- Sure.
Well, actually my next slide addresses
some of those questions because
we look at the predictors,
and that's a busy table.
So I just wanted to communicate
the main message here.
So we looked at demographic
factors or events,
perceived refugee
environment is the quality
of the current environment.
That includes access to
facilities, living conditions,
the social context within
the family and the community,
so a whole range of different factors.
This is a measure that
we created from scratch
based on various pilot studies.
And we also looked at child/caregiver,
child relationship and caregiver
mental health symptoms.
And what you can see is that
war events are important.
They predict all the
outcomes that we looked at,
but actually the strongest predictor
was the current environment.
And so the higher the score,
the higher the quality
of their environment.
So that's why you see the
negative relationships here,
but the effects of the current environment
is much higher than that of war events.
An important predictor was
also maltreatment in the family
and also caregiver mental health problems.
- Michael, could I, could
I ask you a question?
Until we find out how to
get this person miked up.
And I know you may be able to say that,
but I'm just going to ask it quickly.
The maltreatment question is obviously
an extremely sensitive question
to ask the families and caregivers.
So, and it's one that's really
interesting to many scholars.
Can you just elaborate a little bit
about how you get these data?
- So this is the ICAST
measure that we used,
and we, so Elie Karam, who
was a co-peer on the study,
they've used that same
measure in previous studies
in similar samples.
So we knew a little bit
from their experience
what questions would be more
acceptable and which less.
And we excluded certain questions
that would be unethical to ask.
- [Catherine] Okay.
- But I think important to
maybe realize here is that
relatively harsh parenting
is much more accepted
in that cultural context
than compared to here.
So it often felt that neither the child,
the children or the parents
would necessarily find it unusual
to report some of the behaviors
that we would find a
bit more alarming here.
- Maybe you could continue,
a question from the room is going to try
and come through the
chat via various people.
- Yeah, so then a very
important finding is
when we asked them, the caregivers,
whether they are interested
in receiving mental health
treatment for the child,
that was only 25% or 25.6%.
So there's quite a disparity
between the children
that seem to be at risk
of significant mental health problems
and the caregivers that
felt that their child
would benefit from treatment.
So we then asked them about
the awareness of services,
and less than 50% were
aware of any services.
We asked them if they've used any,
and only very few used any
of the available services.
The majority of services
used where those delivered
in the communities.
And then we asked them about reasons
why they are not using services.
Most of them said, well,
they don't have a need for treatment.
And for those that have
a need for treatment
but still did not use
them, the reasons were
that they were not aware
of services or didn't know,
did not know how to access them,
thought that they were too expensive.
There were transport issues.
Lebanon doesn't really
have public transport,
so that's a big challenge.
And then a few people
also mentioned stigma
and security issues.
So I have quite a few
other findings to share.
So I'd like to move on,
but I'll come back to
some of those findings
and what they could mean.
So the second set of,
well, actually two studies
is looking at risk and resilience.
And the question that we were
addressing here is firstly,
you wanted to see how many
Syrian refugee children
could we consider as
resilient within that sample.
Second question, what
factors differentiates
the resilient children from those at risk?
And the third question, how
does resilience change over time
and what predicts those changes?
And then what is the directionality
of detected associations
when looking at development
of resilience over time?
And this is the work
conducted by my PhD student,
Cassandra Popham,
who is in the process of
writing up all these findings.
So the first question
is what is resilience
and how do we define resilience?
Lots of people define
resilience in different ways.
So we stuck to a fairly simple definition.
Resilience is positive
development despite adversity.
So basically refugee
children that experienced war
but did not develop
mental health problems.
That's our definition of resilience.
And we did that across
multiple dimensions.
So many studies that look at resilience
may only look at depression
or only look at PTSD.
But we said a resilient child
is one that is below the cutoffs
of these three outcomes
here, below depression,
PTSD and externalizing problems.
And that was about 20% of the sample.
So 20% were below these three cutoffs.
We didn't consider anxiety
because anxiety didn't differentiate well
between risk and resilience.
If a child was above one or more cutoffs,
they were considered in
the risk, at risk group.
And that was the remaining 80%.
So we had about 20% that
we considered resilient,
and 80 at risk for mental health problems.
In the next step, we look at war exposure,
and you can, war exposure
was measured with a scale
with 25 items.
So usually that's used by just summing up
all those different war
events in the total scale.
But we wanted to look more
carefully at war exposure.
And we also, in addition
to the total score
looked at sort of the different types
that children experience,
the different types of war
exposure that they have.
So there was a small number of children
that didn't report any war exposure.
Important as well, war exposure
was based on child report
and caregiver report.
If any of them reported a war event,
then we considered them as happened.
So it was the combination of
child and caregiver reports.
So there was some children
predominantly experienced bombardment,
but not any of the others.
So they were in that theoretical
group of bombardment,
and the most, most severe was bodily harm.
Basically if children
experienced bodily harm,
they experienced most of
the other events as well.
We created those different groupings
in order to match children
based on their war exposure.
So we matched, we selected
the resilient children,
all of the resilient children
and tried to match each of these children
with one that is at risk,
so is in the risk group,
but has similar war exposure.
So we matched them, for
each resilient child,
we tried to find one child
that has the same total score
in war exposure, but also
the same theoretical group.
So for example, this child
here is in the resilient group
and experienced bodily harm
and has a fairly high score.
We matched that child with another child
that is in risk group that has high,
that has mental health problems
and similar war exposure
in order to look at individual differences
and what predicts why are some children
that have the same war exposure
than children that have
mental health problems,
why do they not have
mental health problems?
So then we conducted logistic regressions
to identify the factors that differentiate
between risk and resilience.
So basically we have children
that have identical war exposure.
Some children developed
mental health problems.
Others did not.
And we wanted to see what
factors differentiate
between the two.
And so we looked at a
whole range of factors
as you can see here.
So these are the odds ratios.
We all, we conducted individual models
for each of these predictors,
but then also combined them
and corrected for multiple corrections.
So the dark blue ones are the
ones that survived corrections
at all, we'll have a look at those.
So self-esteem was one of them.
Self-esteem might be a correlate
of good mental health, right?
So we don't really say with this analysis
whether this is a
correlate or a predictor.
It's just something that
differentiates this group.
Children in the resilience group
tend to have higher self-esteem.
Children in the risk group,
tend to have caregivers
with more PTSD problems,
experienced more child maltreatments,
have caregivers with high depression,
experience more loneliness,
and also have higher scores
in environmental sensitivity.
This is a temperament trait
that reflects heightened
sensitivity to the environment,
both negative and positive experiences.
So this is what we found,
and then the next study,
we wanted to look at the
change in resilience over time.
And this is a quite a busy figure here,
but basically we have the baseline,
and we have the follow up data.
At baseline, that's
just what I showed you.
20% are in the resilience group,
and the remaining 80%
in the high risk group.
When we look at those groupings,
again at the followup,
we do see that now at the followup,
there's 30% in the resilient group,
and about 66% in the high risk group.
However, there is
considerable change over time.
There is a group that is
stable, stably resilient,
but there is a significance,
about half of the children,
that are in the resilient
group at wave one,
are no longer in the
resilient group at wave two.
So that means they had
a significant increase
in mental health problems.
And we define that at least a 20% change
in one of the mental health outcomes.
So they are above at least one cutoff
and at least 20% changed.
So it's not just a minimal change,
just slightly above the cutoff.
These are significant changes.
On average the change that
we saw is 40% increase.
- So, Michael, I have another question
to try to understand this picture.
So the definition of risk here
is if they've been exposed to war.
- No, the definition of risk here
is being above at least one of the cutoffs
of our three mental health outcomes.
- So, Michael, can I ask
you a question as well?
And you also have a question in the chat.
You know, we've discussed that,
given that our work for instance
is actually measuring resilience
as opposed to assuming it's defacto
from the presence or absence
of mental health symptoms,
there was a reason why
you did not do that.
And that's probably because you
work in a younger age group,
but I'm just wondering why you
call them resilience and risk
instead of calling them
just low-risk and high-risk.
In other words, why do you
label them resilient children
because that is not measuring resilience,
it's measuring the absence of symptoms.
- Yeah, so, these are all valid points.
So we refer to them as resilient
when we matched them on the war exposure
because they had war exposure,
but they did not develop
mental health problems.
In the current analysis actually,
we talk about low and high risk
because they're not
matched to war exposure.
Here we just look at low,
basically low mental health
and high mental health health.
- But the word exposure definition,
it refers to events prior to the baseline.
- Yes, yep.
- Could it be that the children
that go from blue to pink
is because they're experiencing new,
so it's not much driven
by their resilience,
but or changing their resilience
but additional environmental factors like.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
That's, that's an important,
it's important to realize
that even though maybe when
we look at war exposure,
some children seem to be resilient.
The context of displacement
itself leads to new trauma.
And even though a child might've
been resilient at one point
doesn't necessarily mean that
child will remain resilient
or will remain at low
risk of mental health,
even in that context of
displacement, we see changes.
Most of the change though
is from children being at higher risk
to no longer be at higher risk,
but it's really a dynamic
development over time
where the majority of
children don't really change,
but some children change,
but not only from higher risk to low risk,
but also from lower risk to high risk.
And I think that's an important message
that we don't think that once
we measure mental health,
and it's low, then it will stay like that
because they're living in
a very challenging context
where they experience neutral as well,
that there is considerable change.
We actually looked in that paper,
we look up the predictors for
all of these different groups.
And I just mentioned some of
the stable high and stable low.
So they're fairly similar
to what I showed earlier.
So it is caregiver mental health.
It's maltreatment.
It's aspects of the family environment,
such as parent conflict
or maternal acceptance,
and then individual factors
such as sensitivity being
higher in those at higher risk.
And self-esteem being higher
in those that are in the low risk group.
- Michael, you have two questions.
So I just want to reiterate,
it's really important
to know that trajectory
has been malleable over time
and that's why intervention is,
you know, really important
at that kind of age group.
So thank you for that message.
You have two questions.
If I can ask you quickly,
Candace (audio blurs) has a question
on how was war events
measured in these analysis?
And you have another question
from the person in the room
on the symptomology when
they report a symptomology
of mental illnesses, whether they were,
I think you answered that.
Were caregiver educated?
Were caregiver told about
the kind of symptomology
of the mental illness
prior to the interview,
or were they just proffered the questions?
So one on the measurement of war events
and the other on the kind
of context information
you gave caregivers
before they answered
questions on mental health.
- So war events were measured
with the war events
questionnaire by a collaborator,
Elie Karam.
He's, that has been
developed for the Middle East
and has been used previously.
It's basically twenty-five
items that you can sum up or,
you know, that was a question
how we should use that data.
So we used the total score.
We've done a whole range
of analysis on that,
and we'll write a paper
as well on the war events,
but basically it's 25 different items
for different sort of typical
war events that happen.
And we ask the child about
that as well as the caregiver.
We ask the child about the war exposure,
the war events they've experienced,
but also the caregiver
about the war events
the child experienced.
And we combine the two.
So it's a pretty solid
measure of war events.
There's still a lot of
issues with that, by the way.
But I don't think I can go into that now.
The mental health, so
caregivers knew a little bit
about this study from
the recruitment process,
but they didn't know about
the specific mental health disorders
when we asked about them.
So we just asked the questions.
They didn't have to complete
the questionnaire themselves.
They were asked in interviews.
So if they had questions,
they could always ask the
interviewer for clarifications.
And these are all established
mental health measures.
And then obviously we created cutoffs
based on clinical interviews.
Okay, the next slide is just one example
of looking at bidirectional relationships
because we have longitudinal data here.
And this is the example
of caregiver depression
and child symptoms.
So the child symptoms
here are standardized
and summed across the three
mental health outcomes.
So this is a continuous
measure of mental health.
And importantly, we
would expect that child,
that caregiver depression
might increase the child
mental health symptoms, right?
But what also find is
that the child symptoms,
the child mental health symptoms over time
has an impact on caregiver depression.
And actually we find for quite a few
of those risk factors.
So it's not just the
environment that has an impact
on the child, but it's also the child
that has an impact on the environment.
And I think that's a very
important aspect as well
to consider for interventions.
And I'll come back to
that in implications.
Let me move on to the biology,
and with the biology,
I'll go a bit quicker.
I could say much about that,
but I'll summarize those findings
a little bit more succinctly.
So we wanted to look here.
So we still, at the beginning
of looking at the biological data,
COVID shutdown the labs in London,
which meant that's a long time
that we couldn't actually
get to our samples,
but everything is analyzed now.
Everything is genotyped,
and everything is ready for analysis.
So we've looked at the hair cortisol
in relation to PTSD and war.
So we wanted to know whether hair cortisol
reflects exposure to war.
We also wanted to look
at whether hair cortisol
is associated with PTSD in children.
So all of this is in children.
And then we've done some work
on the role of epigenetics
in psychological resilience,
and that reflects work by
my postdoc Demelza Smeeth.
And so first question,
we looked at war exposure and cortisol,
and we did find associations,
but they were not very robust.
When we included age of the children
that correlation was
no longer significant.
What we then did, we
looked at the association
between war events and cortisol,
depending on the age of
exposure of the children.
And what we found was really interesting
in that there was an association,
but only in children that
were in their adolescent years
during the exposure to war,
suggesting that adolescence
is a sort of sensitive period
or critical period for longer
lasting biological embedding
of war exposure.
So that was only in that group
that were older than 12 years.
We then looked at PTSD,
and we found that there
was a robust association
between PTSD and cortisol,
even when controlling
for all the covariates.
And we have a lot of covariates,
and we control for all of them.
In the next step we looked
at the mediating effects.
We wanted to see whether war exposure,
whether cortisol or PTSD mediates
the effects of war exposure.
And what we found is that
there is a partial mediation
between of the effect of war
exposure and cortisol by PTSD.
When we ran the opposite testing,
where the cortisol was mediating effects
between war and PTSD,
there was also a partial
mediation, but it was a lot less.
So it seems the case
that war leads to elevated hair cortisol,
particularly in those
children that develop PTSD
in relation to the war exposure.
And I'll leave it at that.
I know that's not very
much, but basically,
so the distance between the war exposure
and the measurement of cortisol
is between two to four years
in our sample.
Right, so that's quite a long distance.
So that's quite a long distance
from the initial exposure.
And that was particularly the case
in children that were in
their adolescent years
during their war exposure.
And I just want to mention
for the role of epigenetics,
we actually haven't analyzed the data yet,
but what we've done,
we've developed the theoretical
framework that we will use
to look at epigenetics,
and to take into account genetic factors
because genetic factors
act upon the epigenome
or DNA methylation,
but they might also be
stable methylation over time,
and then obviously there
are protective factors
and adversity that's together
then results in epigenetic signatures
that are associated with resilience.
There's a lot more to be
said about that, but I don't,
we don't have any analysis yet,
but this is basically the
framework that we're gonna use.
I'm happy to share that paper
with anyone that's interested
in having a closer look at that,
but let me move on to the treatment
of Syrian refugee children
and how to do that over telephone.
We thought that was a really
innovative thing to do,
and then COVID-19 hits, and
suddenly the whole world
was doing treatment over the telephone.
But actually when I was
thinking about the idea,
and I spoke to several people
in the field before COVID,
most people said, no,
we don't really do that
in those settings, and
no one was, you know,
even thinking about
doing that in the future.
But why could it be important?
Well, we know that children
that experience war
are at the higher risk for development
of mental health problems,
but also that many
don't receive treatment.
And that's for a range of reasons.
It's often very difficult
to set up new services
in those settings.
It's difficult to recruit qualified staff,
and refugees are often not mobile.
They can't just go to
a clinic that easily.
So we wanted to adapt
an existing treatment
for delivery over telephone,
with the help of trained and
supervised lay counselors.
And then we wanted to evaluate
the feasibility,
acceptability and efficacy
of this new treatment with
Syrian refugee children
in Lebanon.
And we were using that, we basically,
using the BIOPATH study to recruit people
into our clinical trial.
And basically these are all the children,
all the families that
said they would like help,
if they met inclusion criteria
for our clinical trial,
they were offered inclusion
in the clinical trial.
If not, they were
receiving other treatments.
We had several psychologists working
and counselors working with us.
So we provided free treatment
to every single person
that was associated with,
affiliated with the family
that participated in this study.
So this is basically the BIOPATH sample.
The intervention is CETA,
Common Elements Treatment Approach.
And this is a modular,
transdiagnostic therapy
developed for those kinds of settings.
And it's based on the most effective
cognitive behavioral therapy components.
We first developed the t-CETA manual
by delivering CETA
face-to-face and some piloting,
and then we run a
randomized control trial,
which ended up being very small
to evaluate the feasibility,
acceptability and efficacy.
The measures that we used
were the same mental health
symptoms scales that we used
for the rest of the BIOPATH study.
We used the same clinical interview.
In addition, we have
in session assessments,
that was the client monitoring form,
which is part of the treatment.
So every session the
counselor is completing
a short assessment of the child.
Also, the PSYCHLOPS was
used at the beginning
and the last session,
as well in the middle.
And then we also completed
some qualitative research.
So we interviewed the counselors
that delivered t-CETA,
and we interviewed 11
families that received t-CETA,
so both the child as
well as the caregiver.
We ended up with a very
small sample in RCT.
It was very difficult
recruiting children and families
into this study.
Actually from all the
children that initially,
and the families that initially
expressed an interest,
only 7% ended up receiving treatment,
even though that treatment was over phone.
Because we ended up
with a very small sample
of about 20 children,
so 10 in the treatment
and 10 in the control condition,
the control condition
was treatment as usual.
We used the patient analysis
approach to help us with that.
And we were able to show that
there are significant treatment effects
of the t-CETA condition
with a moderate effect size
of 0.33.
- Sorry to interrupt.
Do you mind saying a little bit
about why you think
the take-up was so low?
I mean, it seems this is a
very vulnerable population.
Are there security concerns?
They don't agree with intervention.
Yeah, it would be great to just--
- Yeah, so we actually have
conducted a qualitative study
exactly on that.
And to some degree when they were asked
to attend the intake session
which was in the clinic,
the intake session was in the clinic.
The treatment was over the
phone or in the clinic,
depending on what they
were randomized into.
Quite a few parents thought
they no longer have,
the children no longer have a problem,
or it's actually not too bad.
I think there were work commitments
that were getting in the way.
Work commitments of the
child or the caregiver,
transport issues.
So quite a few logistic problems,
but also I would say a
limited understanding
of mental health problems
that need treatment.
So these were some of
the points that came up,
but we we're still working
on the analysis of that data.
- And Michael,
that's a really interesting
observation actually,
but I'm just flagging that we
have seven minutes left, so.
- Yes, yes I will, I will get through.
So the positive effects of the treatment
was mostly driven by the
reduction in depression symptoms.
Then we also looked at
the in-session assessment,
and you can see here with
the client monitoring form
that there is really a very
steep decrease over time
in all the children
that receive treatment.
That was also shown in the PSYCHLOPS,
which measures problems,
functioning, well-being.
So it was hard baseline and
then significantly reduced
towards the final session,
and these changes were significant.
The qualitative findings, I
could say a lot about that,
but I'll keep that really short.
So we looked at the feasibility
by interviewing the counselors.
Three themes emerged.
Basically they found that
delivering therapy over the phone
solves some problems,
but it also creates some
additional practical
and logistical challenges
such as bad connections with the phones
or finding a space where
the child could speak
without being heard by others.
They generally found that
the t-CETA was adapted well
to overcome cultural blocks
and that t-CETA works
and is needed.
To some degree, they were
surprised that it worked
as well as it did.
I think some of the counselors
were quite skeptical
whether this would work,
but generally they found
that it would work.
When we interviewed the
caregivers and the children,
four themes emerged,
actually quite similar.
Again, that it solves some problems,
but also creates some challenges,
that t-CETA works for most families,
but there are some challenges that remain
in other families that
can't be solved easily
because the challenging context
remains a challenging context.
Another factor was that the relationship
between the counselor and
the child and caregiver
was very important
and that a family's
attitude to mental health
was also very important.
Important to mention,
this intervention was not just focusing
on the individual child,
but there was also a
parenting component to it.
So caregivers were involved in it.
So let me, in the last few
minutes, discuss what we found.
So basically we found mental
health problems are frequent.
Every second child reports
significant problems.
25.6% of caregivers when asked
said they would like to receive
treatment for their child.
So that suggests there is a
significant perceived need
for mental health services and
also willingness to use them.
However, the majority of these children
never received treatment.
And that is to various barriers.
We found that about 20% of the sample
met our criteria for resilience.
That is a lot less than in other studies,
and the reason it's a lot less
is because we defined resilience
as being below the cutoffs
of multiple dimensions
of mental health outcomes.
If we would have looked at only PTSD
and considered anyone
that is below the cutoff
for PTSD for resilience,
our resilience proportion
would be much more similar
to previous studies,
but it's really important to look at it
across multiple dimensions.
And we identified a range of factors
that are associated with
risk and resilience.
We found that war exposure
and mental health problems
are associated with biological factors
and that biological embedding
seems to be particularly
in those children the
case that were exposed to
in adolescence.
We successfully adapted a treatment
to be delivered over telephone.
Children allocated to t-CETA,
so telephone-delivered CETA
significantly improved over time,
but the randomized controlled
trial was very small,
and findings need to be
replicated in larger studies.
But the qualitative research suggests
that both counselors and
families that received help
found the treatment effective.
But t-CETA may not be
a solution that works
in every situation and every family.
And I want to end with
some of the implications.
The main implications of this
is that many refugee children
suffer from significant
mental health problems.
We know that, but that number
is actually quite high.
And most of these children
never receive treatment.
And even when we offer them
treatment over the phone,
most of them don't receive treatment,
and actually quite a few
children that receive treatment
drop out of treatment.
We have a lot less dropout
in the phone condition,
but with traditional services,
many children will drop out.
We've identified several
predictors that point to the family
and the wider social context
as particularly relevant.
And this means interventions should focus
not just on the individual,
but also the social context.
So systemic approaches
are particularly important
as well as the mental
health of the caregiver
is very important.
We need to treat the
caregiver's mental health
in order to help the child.
So standard delivery of
treatment and programs
that are usually delivered in clinics
is unlikely to reach children in need.
Treatment over phone will
overcome some of those barriers,
but not, will be not sufficient.
Will not be sufficient.
I think what is really needed
is community-based approaches
that involve community members
and that reach not only the child
but also the social
context, the caregivers,
that will be absolutely
crucial to reach more children
and to overcome this treatment gap.
Just an acknowledgement
of my research partners
of the various funding that we received.
And I thank you very
much for your attention.
- Thank you very much, Michael.
Thank you very much for threading
all these disciplines
through: epigenetics,
psychology, community-based programming.
Thank you very much indeed.
When I see your last slide,
I see you need an
anthropologist on your team,
but most importantly, you know,
maybe you could just say a few
words on your local partners
because community-based
approaches are spearheaded
by local partners.
Could you just tell us
a little bit about that?
And then if there are other questions,
please raise your hand
and put them in the chat.
I know there was just a detailed question
on the CETA approach,
how many sessions and over
what time was that provided
to people to accept.
But I'd really like to
ask you a quick question
on how local partners took this together.
Not just the people who were
implementing in the field,
but how they co-designed perhaps,
or co-implemented or see the
future directions of your work.
- Yeah, so this is, this
is future directions.
We are working on developing
a community-based approach
based on our experience in Lebanon.
And we, in order to
increase the recruitment
into the randomized control trial,
we've been running sessions
in the settlements,
and those have been very helpful.
And that's really sort of where we felt
that we really have to do
something in the settlements,
because for them to leave
for refugee families,
especially many, many of
those have many children.
So if one child has a problem,
what do they do with
all the other children?
That's an issue.
And so that makes them much more,
much less likely to
actually seek services,
even if they're provided not
too far from the settlement,
because it's difficult to get there.
So yeah, delivering services
right in the settlements
is what they told us what they would like.
But also there is some stigma issues.
They wouldn't like that other people know
that they received treatments.
That was more problem, more a
problem in some settlements,
less in other settlements.
So there was quite a bit of
variability between settlements,
but we found that they
actually were very engaged.
So we went, I was, we
designed the sessions.
We went with local staff
into those settlements
and delivered those sessions.
Well, I didn't deliver them,
but our field stuff
delivered them in Arabic.
And we had large groups
joining in these discussions
and very lively discussions.
And it was actually quite
helpful to identify families
that really are worried about
their child because they,
there is significant problem.
Whereas there were quite a
few that thought, you know,
the treatment may be,
you know, interesting,
but they don't necessarily,
didn't see a clear need.
I think big part of that
would be psycho education,
to inform them about the
problems that we typically see
in children and at what
level do they need treatment.
But also I think an
important aspect would be
to maybe deliver some
sessions on resilience
and what promotes resilience
and families, strengthening
families and parenting.
So that's what I would do.
What I think would be very crucial
is to recruit community
members from those settlements
to actually deliver some
of that or co-deliver that
and co-create it.
I think that's absolutely key.
- Thank you.
Are there any quick questions?
Most of our participants say
thank you for a great talk,
but have to go at this cutoff
point before nightfall.
This is winter.
I'm just checking, but mostly
thank you very much indeed.
Michael, that was a
really great presentation.
I'm actually going to ask
you one more question.
Sorry, I'm really interested in this
because in the Middle Eastern context,
gender is a big dimension.
So we know that PTSD is
different across gender.
And maybe that, I know
you probably treated that
as a covariate rather than anything else,
but do you have any last
thoughts on the gender dimension
of your work.
Interestingly the caregivers
were mothers, right?
Do you have any?
- Yes, so we actually, so we
looked at the prevalence rates
separately between boys and girls,
and externalizing problems,
as you can imagine,
are more prevalent amongst boys,
and depression more amongst girls.
So there are some differences
I don't remember regarding war exposure,
whether there was some difference.
I could imagine that
the boys are more likely
to experience war exposure
because they're more likely
to be outside than the girls.
I think that's also the
case in the settlements.
Some of the families that I visited,
it seemed that the children
are mostly within the tent
or within the contain they were living in.
Whereas in other families,
the children were just
basically outside all the time
by themselves.
So it could vary quite a bit
between different families.
Yeah.
- Anyway, thank you very
much for that big picture,
for the very careful detailed
analysis of people in need.
And it was a pleasure
to have you talk to us
at Yale, and thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
Thanks for inviting me.
And thanks for the patience.
I realize there's a lot of findings,
but I'm excited about all our findings.
I sort of wanted to share
what we have at this stage,
and there's obviously,
there's lots more to
be done with the data.
And if anyone is
interested to collaborate,
please get in touch with me.
Anyone, that might be possibility.
- Well, yours is a landmark study,
so thank you very much indeed.
Take good care.
- You're welcome.
Take care!